[Music]
in chuck-e-cheese from a birthday dude
do you know his story oh yeah really
that person has a lot of good friends
because that was a really good birthday
for that person I just heard that that
person just called the person that
planned that party not their friend
today as a same person that planned that
party at that same place gave a t-shirt
of that place yeah person that person
must be very nice to have a person that
tells them that their friends not
friends
what's the Statue this was submitted by
whom submitted by Joe's friend oh that
person like [ __ ] when Joe's friend says
that Joe is not a friend of that friend
of that person yeah cuz it's funny I
just want to say I'm sad in this artist
I'm so confused and I just want to
cheese pizza and I have a hair I love
chunky cheese P recently no cuz cuz I
I'm wondering if I'm just remembering
liking Joey cheese pizza or if I really
like it they won't let us in there did
you ever have fedko pizza no I'm fascist
Coco was the wouldn't it change into
this Martin final it was like a good
cost glove it's time kind of oh yeah
yeah yeah headquartered in Montgomery
Ward's in one of those places it's a
price Club Price Club how brazen Costco
right yeah [ __ ] I forgot but it was good
it's not smart funny thing kind of like
a Walmart yeah but you go to the end you
need membership and you go to the end
and there's a glaring cafeteria and it
was good dude we should just get it to
check your cheese pizza to go and try it
oh my god did you guys hear what Nicky
just said well that's a really cute
story tell me
do you really want it you wanna know
something creepy I did recently well I
know okay sorry I don't I'm not even I'm
not gay so uh I had to go run an errand
for Nicky he was like nineteen Oh God
and I had to go to a drugstore tampon
run I need to do that too no and I had
to go get her prescription for something
right yeah I was a couple months ago
yeah so I was getting an icky
prescription filled told me that it was
going to take like 25 minutes and so I
was like well [ __ ] and so I walk her
outside and I saw a Chucky Cheese and I
walked into the Chuck E Cheese just
because I wanted to smell but without a
kid well no I walked in and I was like
I'm gonna get my book my mic like my
nephew or whatever and I just walked in
just to smell Chuckie Cheese real quick
and then I was like I'll see him and I
love the next [ __ ] creepy it is
really creepy this is [ __ ] creepy
but I was like a boy you know you get
more that's so sad in a prescription oh
yeah what pharmacy is open at night what
are you talking about all pharmacies
open until like 9:00 yeah it was like 7
Y has to be open for intricate cheese to
be open yeah Chuckie Cheese employees by
a kid presents after no one shows up for
his party what it's really impossible I
wouldn't give the mom [ __ ] cuz she did
say that she gave 30 invites to his
kindergarten class and no one was it
like you get so cool so cool so cool
quit first school semester and then a
month later there was like no follow-up
or reminder and
it's like nobody should what if this kid
is a [ __ ] and no one likes him that
could beat what if the parents didn't
like the mom and the reason why I say
that is because my so my brother my
sister-in-law sister just had a baby
shower and she invited everyone but
didn't do a follow-up like a week before
and she said the invitation like a month
ago
like a month before I mean and like five
people should yeah this kid's birthday
like Christmas day or some [ __ ] I mean I
always wonder about those those kids I
don't know anybody that doesn't want to
go to a party as a kid as a kid yeah
especially if it's at Chuck E Cheese
true even if he's like [ __ ] Zack who
we all hate like it's like I'll go to
Turkey Jack yeah that's different
yeah it's like [ __ ] that guy but it's
[ __ ] Chuckie Cheese yeah yeah or if
it's did you - no - kids birthdays
you're getting invited a lot I didn't
why there was this girl at my school who
told everybody she was the popular girl
and she had the most parties and shade
the coolest parties cuz her parents were
getting divorced and they were fighting
over like there was like giving the best
parties to like trying to win her
elementary in elementary school and she
was a popular girl and she told
everybody that if they were my friend
that they weren't invited to any of her
parties you have neighbors that had
birthdays and you walked into their
house
I had my cousin's birthday that's like
all the birthday kid you were like and I
know which neighborhoods you lived it
did you ever did you ever go to a
birthday party @dz the Discovery Zone
discovering places what that I had never
known we're going to Discovery Zone it's
how we started having like you know like
you're actually I saw the commercials
and all my cousin's birthday parties I
went there once but they were like young
we've got poor you never had friends
around the neighborhood not really I
lived in a condo the condominium so like
it wasn't like it was a lot of old
people that retired people were there we
used to do pizza Fridays and my friend
would make pizza in his woodfire oven
the whole neighborhood it was so soon
neighborhood yeah yeah yeah we were all
super close that's - I like that yeah
I like - unlike the whole comedians time
they all know each other's names that
you just come here oh yeah then their
parents would would parent the other
kids - look if I [ __ ] up like I get
yelled at by the parent and my mom would
be like thank you I like that - yeah we
had that in the hood but like um they
ever were knew each other if they were
just all doing that [ __ ] but no one was
tight though like that I never knew any
of my neighbors ever growing up ever
mm-hmm really
I knew all my neighbors are now on your
it was dope I like that we knew them but
they didn't have birthday parties no
parties I had a lot of elementary school
friends like in my four blocks or
whatever and then so after school we
would bike around and people would all
go to each other's houses I want
stranger things I'm like that's how it
was with me yeah that's so bad sometimes
you just ride your bike you just ride
your bike by yourself do you know what
to do and then all of a sudden your pack
turns into like four other people
because I just ride in the back we have
our bikes we get Jack to buy older kids
but it's just because you're being yeah
we'd also got if some kid just randomly
wants our bike well hey get the [ __ ] out
of here you little [ __ ] like this is
not for you well this is how it was well
yeah like you'll just turn into a flock
of that's why I would kids had birthday
parties and stuff and other kids just
walk by most people would just be like
come over yeah cuz they know it's like
they're from the same school or whatever
I always lived way too far from my
school were you one of the kids that got
chartered away no it's a charter school
or some [ __ ] like far from your
neighborhood
all right oh you know you know that you
didn't go to school in your school zone
yeah see I live near elementary school
so I feel like the people that grew up
there their parents probably bought
houses there so they could send their
kids and like walk them to school or
whatever it took for it to be closed
that was fun
so this story here it's about little
Evan he was turning four years old and
there's almost came out to them a
picture just a baby version of him but
it looks just like bar Danny's not
stress I never think about words they
give a four-year-old kid you have a
birthday party coming up you have the
birthday party oh I hope that people
come they're not gonna remember [ __ ]
that's we were stressed about overtake
us birthday he's gonna remember it he's
won right I'm not gonna read it
well what grade are you in for right now
you're ready to start kindergarten yeah
I'll remember my baby baby you started
at four rocktober tank is worth exams
like 60 people but I don't remember
birthday parties kindergarten first
grade or any of that [ __ ] yeah so Evan
during his birthday party no one showed
up and he was really upset but the mom
she tried to like keep a happy face and
so there was an employee I want to spend
it with you [ __ ] that's what he's
saying
mm-hmm you boring you [ __ ] tell me
what it do all day yeah so this this
worker her name is Taylor she noticed it
and she just felt like really upset
about the fact that no one showed up for
this little boy's birthday it sucks
wrote on Facebook that she wanted to
give the kid a party with presents and
her family her colleagues family members
and friends responded and within three
to four days she had thirteen gifts for
Evan oh so they invited and his mom back
to took a cheese but didn't tell them
anything about the presents and so when
they got there they surprised Evan with
all the gifts oh he's cute he's super
cute
no Chuckie looks different hey I know I
don't like how they made him skinnier
that's a rebrand locked up he's like
crackhead Chuck you know what happened
yeah
yeah yeah
he had a fatter face he's gonna Atkins
gifts that they gave oh man this is
Taylor who made it all happen that's
very nice of her like blonde Howard
Stern blonde hipster blonde Howard Stern
who's that his mom no oh very nice of
you that's very sweet
yeah super suit and then the mom is just
super grateful obviously I don't like
what they did to Chucky man nah they did
a Chucky makeover or something he was
always creepy buddy's looks extra green
banana I think that was way cuter before
it was cute he's no Mickey Mouse but he
was really cute it's furry though let me
see how I'm gonna show you guys if it
ain't broke you know why they would they
change that of all the things change the
purple guy he's the [ __ ] serious what
is that McDonald to you as scary as fun
yeah a red afro with Chinese eyes as
we're looking dude purple John guys the
scary one change em holy [ __ ] shrubs guy
[Music]
like he's making the pizzas he's the one
that's making me here's the progression
of ones grow all the way to looks like
one of those pictures they actually
found a giant mouse in the wild that's
what I said are you writing the pizza or
the kitchen yeah yeah yeah yeah I think
the the Red Hat one is what I remember
yeah
[Music]
[Music]